Hello, everybody!
I... fucked up.
Okay, there's a lot of stuff in regards of...
How did you fuck up, Doki?
Well...
Let's just say...
Okay, so we all know I have this really big problem regarding saying no.
So, remember when I was telling you guys, like, oh, hey guys, I had a deadlocked tournament invitation.
But I'm gonna say no to it.
So, guess who didn't say no?
Guess who didn't say no at the last minute?
So, what happened?
What happened was that...
I was talking with Gumi yesterday.
Like, I was on a call with her.
And I was, like, she was talking to me about deadlock because she's obsessed with deadlock right now.
And, like, it's literally, she was like, I don't even like Valorant anymore.
All I do is play deadlock.
And I was like, oh, that's funny.
That's so funny.
Cause, like, I actually got invited to a deadlock tournament.
That's like a charity tournament for tomorrow.
But, like, I didn't, like, I forgot to say no.
Cause, like, I was going to, but then I got really sick.
So, like, I was gonna reply to them and say no.
And then, she was like...
Oh, why didn't you say no?
I was like, well, I couldn't get a team going.
And the only person I knew that played deadlock was Surefour.
And you.
I was like, I didn't really know how to get a team going on.
And then she was like, I can get you a team.
And, like, do you think you still have that spot?
I was like...
I don't know.
I mean...
I mean, if you really want to play, I can...
I can ask if they still have that spot.
And she's like...
Oh, yeah.
I mean, if they say...
If they still have it, we can do it together.
I was like...
Okay.
You know, I'm just like, there's no way they still have that spot.
The tournament is literally in two days.
By the way, it's tomorrow.
Cause, like, this all happened yesterday.
So, I was like, oh, there's no way.
There's no way they still have this spot.
The tournament is in two days.
And now, today...
I got a message back.
And they were like...
Oh, we actually still need one more team.
And anyway...
So, like, I mean, if you have a team...
And then, I looked at the thing.
I looked at the guide.
And they sent me the package of, like, the instruction.
And then...
And then, I was like...
Wait.
This is a European tournament.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
This tournament is in European hours.
What the fuck is...
What is 4 CEST?
And then, like...
Cause they're like...
The tournament starts at 4 CEST.
And I was like...
What the fuck is CEST?
By the way, for those who don't know what CEST is...
It's Central Eastern European Time.
So, I was like...
What the fuck?
And then...
So, I was like...
4 CEST to PST.
7 in the fucking morning?
I was like...
And then, I messaged back.
And I was like...
Excuse me.
So, it says...
Is this a European tournament?
And then, they replied back.
Yes.
It's casted.
It is for, like...
It is hosted in London.
And I was like...
What?
I was like...
That's 7 in the morning.
That's 7?
And I was like...
I'm sorry.
And then...
I thought that was my way out.
You know?
I was like...
Oh...
It's 7 in the morning.
We're not gonna do 7 in the morning.
So, I was like...
Oh, I'm sorry.
I can't.
It's 7 in the morning.
I can't do it.
That's way too early.
And they're like...
Well, we can put you in the...
We can put you at the 12 p.m.
category.
And I was like...
You're supposed to say...
Okay.
Oh...
And then I messaged Goofy.
I was like...
Hey...
So, you know how we're not gonna do it?
Because it's 7 in the morning?
Have a 12 p.m.
Like, do you still wanna do it?
She's like...
Yeah.
I mean, it's 12 p.m.
It's not 7 in the morning.
So, like...
Yeah.
We can...
I can do that.
I'm like...
Oh...
I
didn't...
I didn't...
I was
like...
I was like...
Dude...
To the organizers, I was like...
Yeah.
I mean, like...
It's too much of a hassle.
Like, I know it's, like, super last minute.
I know...
I know it's...
I know it's super last minute.
So, it's okay.
It's okay if, like...
If, like...
You know...
If you guys don't wanna do this anymore.
Like...
It's so much to organize putting us in this tournament.
I'm so sorry.
And they're like...
No, no.
It's totally fine.
Like...
We totally understand.
We're so happy to have you.
And I'm just like...
Oh...
So...
Um...
Tomorrow...
I'm doing...
I'm...
A...
A deadlock charity tournament.
Um...
I'm doing a deadlock charity tournament at...
Uh...
At 12...
12pm.
And we don't have a full team.
We don't have a full team finalized yet.
But...
Who...
I...
I know...
Currently...
That...
It's me...
Gumi...
And Sejam.
And then...
Gumi and Sejam are gonna find the final three.
I...
I don't know if...
I don't know who the other three are.
I just know that...
That is my current team.
Right now.
To think of the children.
So we're...
We're...
Just kidding.
I'm not...
No!
I can't just...
I can't!
I'm in too deep!
And it's for charity!
Guys!
It's...
I'm still...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is it too late for you to say just kidding?
I'm not actually taking part.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So...
It's for charity.
I...
It's for the kids.
And I...
I'm already in too deep.
I'm in too deep right now.
So...
That's...
Basically...
The...
I have eight streams for the rest of the week.
So...
Like...
I have three days where I'm doing double streams.
So...
Cause I don't know who else plays...
I don't know who plays deadlock at a decent level.
I was...
I don't...
I don't fucking know!
Like...
I literally...
The only reason I was going to say no was cause like...
I only knew Surefour and Gumi.
I...
And then I was...
Surefour was like...
Nah.
And then...
And then we...
And then Gumi and I tried peer pressure Surefour again today.
Cause we're like...
Cause I asked Surefour again today.
And he was like...
I thought you said no.
And I was like...
Well...
And then I was like...
Um...
I was going to...
But then like...
Gumi convinced me.
And then he was like...
Well...
And I was like...
Oh...
It's at like...
It's at 12.
And he was like...
Oh...
I have Dungeons and Dragons.
So even if I wanted to...
I couldn't.
And I'm like...
God fucking...
I couldn't.
I was just like...
I was just like God fucking dammit!
He had Dungeons and Dragons to carry me.
He's literally the deadlocked streamer right now!
I thought...
I thought you could help him get the games over with.
He could literally 1v5 all of them for us.
He could have 1v5'd all of them!
And then the game would be over.
The games would have been so quick.
Dude, priorities.
So...
Patoki D&D is important.
Psychos, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, what's this?
The consequences of my own actions?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, by the way... wait, it hasn't been... oh, it hasn't been announced, but like...
I even have a double stream on Sunday.
I have a double stream on Sunday.
I have an unannounced... another unannounced tournament.
Um, that was...
I'm sponsored for that one, by the way.
Like, I'm not...
Like, um...
I'm sponsored for that one, by the way.
I have an unannounced Sunday tournament that I'm sponsored to be in.
And then...
Um, and then I also have another stream on that day.
Another collab on that day, uh, that Gumi invited me to.
So, it's gonna be, like, nine days of, like...
Not only... By the way, I also have a lot of work behind the scenes!
I have so much stuff to do!
Oh my god, I don't know how I got into this situation again!
I don't...
Every time!
I don't know how I keep getting into this situation!
I'm, like, sick at everything, too!
Oh my god.
So, that's how...
That's how the Deadlock tournament um... came to be.
By the way, guys...
They were, like, the tournament organizer was, like...
Oh, yeah!
But, like, um...
But, like...
It's a two-day tournament, but it's, like, knockout stages, so if you make it to the second day, they were, like, we're starting at six in the morning on this day, too, by the way.
Like, are you sure that's okay?
And then I was, like, we're not gonna make it to day two, so I hope to god we...
I hope to god I did not jinx us right there.
I straight up was, like, it's all right.
We're not gonna make it to day two.
So, we'll see.
We'll see tomorrow.
We'll see tomorrow what's gonna happen.
Because I was, like, we're not gonna throw.
We're not gonna throw.
But we're gonna see what happens.
It's like...
I don't know how I got into this situation.
Women who refuses to say no.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
So, there's that.
That's one life.
There's a lot of life updates, by the way.
I made a list.
Another life update.
Brazil is back on Twitter!
Okay, this is a world update.
I just wanted to notify you guys this, but Brazil has finally been unbanned on Twitter.
Because I know some of you guys actually use me as a news source.
So, like, I just wanted to give you guys an update on the world news.
So, welcome back, Brazil, on Twitter!
Welcome back!
Yeah!
You guys are back!
It got unbanned!
We are back, but I have no Twitter.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Well, time to throw.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Another life update.
So...
Oh my god.
You know what's crazy?
Okay, this is actually crazy.
I did not realize pro players actually like, you know, like, I could see that from, like, source...
Oh, she cast!
Thank you for the super chat!
I saw it on Twitter!
Which is my news source.
Twitter is my news source, and I know I'm somebody's news source on this chat.
Anyway, so, I know, like, in Japan, it's, like, very common to, like, for, like, Japanese, like, pro players and, like, um, like, esports people to, like, have, like, Oshis and VTuber Oshis.
But I was so surprised.
Okay, so you remember when I told you guys that, like, I think Effect is a dragoon?
Okay, so I found out, like, after the tournament, I found... this actually...
I was so surprised.
So, after the tournament, he told me that, um, when I was, you know, when I... before I came back to being an indie, he used to... and, like, uh, I met Effect because we got in a team together for those, like, random tournaments.
And those, like, random tournaments, you know, like, pro players where, uh, you swap teams every... every game and stuff.
So I got him in a game one time, you know, before I came back to an indie.
I got him in... in one of my team for one of those tournaments.
So I thought that's how, like, he knew about me.
But apparently, he actually actively watched me before that happened.
And he didn't even... he wasn't even watching, like, Apex streams.
He was watching just, like, my streams in general.
And then... so he was like, oh my god, when I got you on my team during that one...
that tournament when we first played together, like, I was fangirling so hard.
And I was like, wait, what?
You're, like, actually a drag?
And he's like, yeah, no, I actually... I was... I watched...
I was... I watched your streams before.
And, like, I was like, wait, how the fuck did you buy my streams?
And then he was like, oh, I was just looking around YouTube.
And, like, I just thought your content was really funny.
And so I was like, wait, do you still watch me?
And then he was like, yeah, whenever I have time from, like, pro play, I try to watch you.
And I'm like, oh my god!
Is that crazy?
He's, like, an actual dragoon!
Holy shit!
That blew my fucking mind!
I was so surprised, because I was like, what the fuck?
You had people like, oh my god, they...
I was so surprised.
Um...
It was very surprising for me, because for me, I'm like, wow, I get to play with pros!
Like, because, like, Effect is, like, literally probably one of the best team... Apex teams in the world.
And, like, and he got, like, he, like, got, like, three times number one pred back to back for three seasons in a row when he was, like, seventeen.
And I'm like, Jesus Christ!
I was like, wait, you watched me?
Like...
I was so... I was so surprised.
Um...
Anyway, that's another update.
And so, like, another life update, by the way.
Another life update.
So, you know how the Minecraft...
Um... the Minecraft block wars thing that we're doing... By the way, I messed up my schedule.
It's at 11 a.m.
It's not 11 p.m.
I hope some people knew I messed up.
Because, like, you know, it's, like, the first stream of the day.
You know, the order is usually the first stream.
So, it's 11 a.m.
Not 11 p.m., by the way.
I fucked up on the schedule.
Um...
Anyway...
Um... So...
When we were... Gumi and I were in the call.
When we were in the call, she was like, hey, you know one of the players on our team?
Like, one of the pro Minecrafters on our team?
And I was like, yeah.
He was in the haunted house Twitch Rivals.
And I was like, oh, God.
He was there?
And she was like, yeah, but do you remember who he was?
And I was like, no.
He was one of the people that started that huge fight in the server.
And I was like, wait!
Because I was like, no, Gumi.
We roasted the shit out of him.
Oh, my God.
On stream.
In front of so many people.
And I was like, no way.
And she was like, no, he's on our team.
And I was like, do you think he remembers us?
Well, now he might remember us because I talked about it.
But I was like, no way.
He was the one that started the huge fucking fight.
Because like...
I'm like, no way.
And I was like, oh, my God.
I was like, Gumi, you don't understand.
We were...
We called them nerds, Gumi.
You don't understand.
There were so many people watching.
We called them nerds, Gumi.
We were roasting them.
He was like, the world will be okay.
Maybe he forgot.
I'm like, well, now he won't because I'm going to talk about it on stream.
Oh, my God.
So there's that, too.
There's so many consequences of my own actions today.
I can't believe every single act of karma is hitting me today.
Guys, everything is just hitting me today right now.
So there's that other update.
Finally, one last update.
Guys, this has nothing to do with my other life updates, but this showed...
Oh, wait, no, I do.
Actually, I do have one more.
A life update for my own life.
So, you know how dad...
By the way, dad's coming back later today.
So he's finally coming home.
I don't think he sees this as home anymore.
So, I got another text message from the babysitter yesterday.
I'm going to be loading screen real quick because I'm bringing up the text message because I was like...
I really wanted to text back.
Is this the same doc?
I wanted to text that back, but I didn't.
I held...
I tried to make sure I didn't say anything.
This is the message I got.
He hasn't barked at any other dogs he has seen during walks, too.
Very good behavior.
And I...
And I was...
And I'm just like...
I told you guys so many stories.
I told you!
For four days!
Four days!
This fucker has not barked at any other dogs!
For four fucking days!
Every time I walk him, I...
Who is he?
I can't be the problem!
What is she doing differently?
I don't understand!
What is she doing differently than me?
So...
So anyway, that's...
He's coming back.
I swear to God.
And I'm gonna walk him, and then he's gonna see a dog and he's gonna be like...
And I'll just be like... Who are you?
And I'm just gonna be like...
I swear to fucking God!
Don't you guys think... No!
He doesn't hate me!
He barks at other dogs, not me!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Anyway, one last update before...
I'm sorry.
There's been like...
A long tangent of life updates.
But this is, um...
One last update.
But basically, um...
Well, it's not an update.
I thought it was really funny.
So, Apex cheats are now pretty insane.
This actually popped up in my For You page, and I was like, the fuck?
So...
The hacks in Apex Legends has come so far that you can literally play an RTS in Apex via cheats.
And what do I mean by that?
So here is the link of what I saw today.
So, basically, um...
One cheater, one hacker figured out how to control five other players.
Five other bots.
And he controls these bots with the pinging system.
And these bots all have aimbot.
So I was blown away.
Cause I was like, wait, what?
Are they all, like, teaming together?
And then they started spectating the guy.
And he was literally playing a fucking RTS.
And so it was it was insane.
It was, it was literally playing an RTS in Apex Legends.
And was controlling them with the ping system.
And I'm like, oh my god.
Cheats have really come this far.
Like, a one man army with five fucking bots.
That's wild.
Like, dude, you just shattered Apex into pieces.
I was so funny.
I was like, who the fuck thought of that?
What the fuck?
Just not checkers.
Gotta respect their efforts.
Bro, one of them is, like, level 21 in Masters.
That guy literally got an account to level 20 and got to Masters in one level.
Like, that's so...
Oh my god.
I just couldn't believe it.
It blew...
I'm sorry.
It blew my mind that somebody actually made an RTS with Apex Legends.
I couldn't...
Cause, like, you know, the hacks I know.
The hacks...
The hacks I know.
You know, what happened to the classic aim botting and, like, aim botting and walls.
It's not... Like, you know, and then you're feeling a little spicy.
You add speed hack in there.
But now there's fucking RTS hacks?
Like, what?
Oh my god.
And then he has five of them.
He has five of them.
That's so crazy.
He's not even aim botting.
He's controlling a band of aim botters.
Okay.
Alright.
That is my...
That is my, like, life update of the day.
You're not even playing the same game anymore.
I know!
Oh my god.
Like...
It's so... So anyway, for those who want to see it, here's the link again for those who want to see the fucking impossible.
Um...
Thank you.
That is just being protective to you.
But, like, what about the other lady?
Alright.
Anyways, Dragon Ball Z time!
I am...
excited to try out the newest Dragon Ball Z game.
I think I talked about my... Oh my god.
Not Dutch.
I talked about my history with Dragon Ball Z.
Um...
And, um...
I watched Dragon Ball... Dragon Ball?
Dragon Ball Z?
Unfortunately, Dragon Ball GT.
Unfortunately.
It was on TV, okay guys?
I had nothing else to do.
Ocean Group dub is the most superior dub.
And, like, for those who are, like, you never even finish the series.
Um, that is a lie, because in Canada, we literally only had Ocean Group dub.
Like, don't fucking...
That's all we had!
That's literally...
That was literally all we had, okay?
Like...
And that... That's all the, um...
That's all the...
Uh...
Um... What anime I watched?
I didn't watch, like, Super or Kai.
I heard Super wasn't that great in terms of quality, but, like, I didn't watch Super or Kai.
I did, um...
Um, I watched... I remember watching a couple of the first move... couple of movies and everything.
Uh, so that is my experience on, um...
On Dragon Ball.
Um...
I like Dragon Ball.
I mean, what else can I say?
I like Dragon Ball, and I think Frieza seems like a really stand-up guy.
And maybe, you know, some of his philosophies...
is...
Wrong!
I don't know what you guys thought I was gonna say.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know what you guys thought I was gonna say, but, like...
That man did not like a lot of people.
Okay.
What do you mean, Doki?
No!
I said, some of his philosophies were wrong!
I don't know what you expected me to say.
Um, Angela, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
RIP to Doc Harris.
Never forget his time in Dragon Ball Z.
Some?
What do you mean, some?
Which one was right, Doki?
Some of his philosophies were wrong.
That's all I'll say.
Alright.
Sound guy, are you around?
Okay, to be fair, Frieza has a really fucking good design.
Like, not the first one.
Which is the one where he's just, like, circles?
Like, not when he was in the... not when he was in that little car thing.
But, like, you know, the full... like, the perfect, the perfect, uh...
form.
His final form.
Yeah, yeah.
His final form was fucking sick.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cooler was better.
It was better than Frieza.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
His last form.
Yeah.
Let's just boost everything to max.
Okay.
Put that...
We'll put 92.
I should have put this at 87.
Alright.
That should be good.
Players can adjust controls.
Uh... Alright.
Continue.
Oh.
Fuck.
Um...
That's...
Oh, man.
That's a lot of words.
Okay.
That's...
Wow.
Okay.
I'm not gonna remember this, guys.
That's...
That's a lot of words on my screen right now.
So...
We'll see... Whoa.
What do any of these mean?
What do...
What do any of these things mean?
Combo assist.
Let's fucking go.
Help me.
Uh...
Follow up attack assist.
Let's go.
Dragon dash assist.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's...
Yeah.
Let's... This is...
Let's go.
Revenge counter assist.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I got this.
Oh, my God.
This is gonna be the easiest game of my life.
Oh, shit.
That looks cool.
That's sick.
I think Vegeta is better than Goku.
Oh, shit.
We're playing?
Oh, my God.
Is this my assist?
Is this...
Whoa.
Okay.
Jump.
Fly.
Am I flying?
Oh, no.
I'm flying now.
Okay.
L1 ascend to descend.
Oh, shit.
R2X.
Wait.
R2... Oh, wait.
That's not X.
Oh, I'm doing it.
Okay.
And then weeeeee.
All right.
There you go.
Thanks, Vegeta, for watching me.
Fun fact.
Frieza is based on the most evil person the creator ever met.
A 90's Japanese real estate agent.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Okay.
And then...
All right.
Cool.
Why can't I just play Vegeta?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
This is so easy.
And then Rush Chain.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Wait.
Is that not it?
Oh, it's a combo.
I thought it was pressing at the same time.
Okay.
Chi Blast.
And then Chi Charge.
Or Ki Charge.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
No.
Stop.
I'm trying to learn.
Where's my baby mode?
Stop.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
Activate and knock your opponent back.
Am I holding it?
Oh, by holding until fully charged.
Oh, hey.
Is he okay?
Is he gonna go on Twitter and type the response?
Wait.
He has to go?
Vegeta, please.
Where are you going?
Gonna go back to your fucking wife?
Okay.
What are you?
What?
Goku doesn't care?
I'm so surprised he even has kids at that point.
I'm just surprised Goku even has kids.
He does not give a fuck about Chi Chi sometimes.
He does not.
Oh, is this Superman opening?
Wait.
Not Superman.
I'm fucking not sorry.
I'm super...
Is this a super opening?
I don't know why is it Superman.
The opening looks really good.
Holy shit.
Is that Luffy from Hunter x Hunter?
Hunter x Hunter is coming back.
I heard.
Actually, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
That's crazy to say though.
Hunter x Hunter is coming back.
Yeah.
It's coming back in like...
I think.
I don't remember.
In like a couple of weeks or something.
Or it did come back already.
Wait.
It's only back for one chapter?
Oh.
That's fucked up.
That's like...
That...
If it's just for one chapter, it's a little...
It gives you like a taste of like...
What if I am coming back, JK?
Oh, 20 chapters?
Hey, that's great.
Access super training from the battle and training tab on the main menu.
Okay, cool.
Okay.
I saw like... Oh, hey!
Those are the gods.
Oh, come forth.
I'm just gonna leave them now.
What does summoning them do?
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but...
Oh, hey!
It's Hercules!
I don't know if you guys know this.
Or Mr. Satan!
But like...
Um...
So I bought the deluxe.
Deluxe?
Cause I was like... Oh, it's only $10 more.
Like from the early access.
So I was like...
Oh, hey!
Um... Let's get all these things.
But like, what are they?
Like...
I'm just like... I saw like...
All the extra items and I'm like...
The fuck is all of this?
Like, I don't know what this does.
Like, what...
Summon Paranga?
Summon Supershed?
What do they give me?
What...
What do they give...
I don't even know.
Oh, are they like gotcha for characters?
What do you usually spend your time doing?
Oh, let's summon Shenron!
Let's do it!
Might as well have it.
It's gotcha time.
Shenron.
I want a pair of underwear.
I want more zeny.
I want more titles.
I want new outfits.
I want to raise my player level.
Let's go gambling!
Which one's characters?
Guys.
Guys, which one is...
Which one is characters?
Guys.
The fuck is zeny?
Oh, zeny for...
The fuck is titles then?
Okay, zeny is characters.
Zeny is... Okay, zeny is money.
Oh yeah, it's the Dragon Ball Z money!
Sorry, I forgot.
It's the Dragon Ball Z money.
It's been a while.
Okay, so we'll get outfits then.
Uh, Sparx, thank you for the super chat.
Your very first super chat.
Thank you.
The beginning of Dragon Ball Super ranges from bad to meh, but it gets better when a tournament destroys... Oh yeah!
The only thing I know about...
Can I just leave?
And like... Oh my god, I'm worried that if I just be like JK...
I'm worried that if I say JK, they'll be like, well, you already used your Dragon Ball.
Okay, I swear to god if he was like, well, you already used it, so... Guess not.
Guess no wish for you.
No...
The only thing I know about Dragon Ball Super was, uh...
was from the World Destroyer...
the turn... like the tournament destroyer's arc, where they're trying to destroy...
The fuck is that?
Is this from Super?
Like, what the fuck is that?
Don't they remember from Shenron?
It's the ultra buff Shenron!
And the...
Is that from Super?
Like, Super the... Bro, what the fuck is wrong with his face?
Okay, I want more characters.
Um...
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, which one?
Which is best?
Fused Zamasu or Goku Black or Evil Goku?
He's beautiful!
Is Goku Black better?
Or Fused Zamasu?
He went super safe.
Goku Black is cooler.
Because he has black in his name.
Alright, Goku Black.
Wish your...
girl...
Yay!
I got Goku Black!
Good luck with... Oh, I heard Great Ape Vegeta is, like, pretty difficult.
Oh, nice!
Alright, let's summon Shenron.
What the fuck?
I missed out so much on the newer Dragon Ball.
Alright, let's get outfits.
Yeah, he's messing everybody up.
I want new outfits.
Oh!
Wait, I want a Vegeta... Wait, what's the Vegeta Super outfit?
Wait, which outfit do I get?
Vegeta Super outfit?
Master Roshi outfit?
Okay, we don't... I don't... Who the fuck would pick Yamcha?
That's all I'm gonna say.
I'm not gonna get a Yamcha outfit.
Who the fuck is gonna pick...
Who even... Who willingly plays Yamcha?
Like, who fucking willingly plays that character?
But it's Yamcha.
Don't say that!
Lots of people.
Yamcha's the real one.
It's like you're asking to lose.
Like, why the fuck would you play Yamcha?
It's not... This is like...
This is like Yamcha with like 500 bots or some shit.
He is the second strongest actor Mr. Satan.
The Yamcha difficulty for gamers.
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna get the...
Alright, just for... Just...
Okay, Yamcha.
You and your 500 bots, I'll get a Yamcha outfit.
Me, I play Yamcha.
Oh my god, it's so...
Oh, it's the Dragon Ball outfit.
Wait, is it right now?
Oh, okay.
Maintain notice.
Okay, I was gonna say I swear to god, I cannot not play now.
Okay, what is...
Alright.
Battle...
Do we do episode?
I guess it's episode, right?
Oh wait, I wanna...
I wanna...
Turn... Alright, guys.
Uh...
Sound guy, is there anything I need to fix?
Sound guy?
Alright, guys.
Because I saw you guys were yelling at me.
And was like, please don't do this to us.
But I still wanna hit.
Okay.
Alright.
I didn't just bring up the sound effects.
Okay, I'll bring... I love the menu so far.
The menu is really pretty.
I think.
Funny fact that what I've heard, Trunks' English voice actor couldn't stop laughing on the line, Hold your fire, that...
What?
Wait.
Is that a real line?
No way.
Wait.
No fucking way.
How did...
How did that...
How did that even get through approval?
No, I have to be Goku?
A warrior who is constantly in search of new...
Oh my god!
That's racist!
Oh wait, am I going straight in?
Oh, this is the movie!
This is when he kidnaps my son!
I already forgot how to play this game.
Oh shit, don't worry!
There's my son!
Wait, he's not?
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid!
Get over here!
That's fucking right!
What you gonna do, huh?
Wait, he's not from a movie?
No, there's... wasn't there a movie with this?
Or is that in Canada?
Guys, the worst part, I watched it all in syndication.
So like, it was mostly from like...
So it was so out of order.
By the way, I watched Dragon Ball Z out of order.
Because I only watched it whenever it like came up on my TV.
Like...
I didn't even know it was episode 1.
Because I literally...
It was so out of order.
I thought it was a movie.
It was part...
God, I'm...
There were so many movies.
Okay, let me beat you up.
No!
Please!
I forgot the moves!
Oh yeah, 100%.
YTV fucking sucked.
That's literally how I watched the show.
Okay, come on.
Get over here!
I only know how to square properly!
Okay, and this too.
And I know how to do that.
Yeah, the movie you're thinking of is the ocean version of The Arrival.
Which is like 2-3 episodes cut up and made...
Yeah!
No, I was right!
I was right!
They made it into a movie on ocean group dub!
I fucking knew it!
I fucking...
You guys tried to gaslight me.
You guys actually tried to gaslight...
It was a Canadian...
I fucking...
I fucking knew it!
Vindication!
Fucking vindication!
If you want your little brat to return safely, Kakarot.
Prove your Saiyan spirit.
Eliminate 100 earthlings and pile them here before I return in one day.
No!
My son!
And let me be very clear about this.
What's wrong with you, Canada?
I come back and I don't see 100 corpses.
I killed the kid.
Oh, he didn't specify human corpses.
It could be anything else.
What even is Canada?
A pixel welcome to the tomato farm.
Come on!
I didn't even recognize him as my son.
Why would I care?
Oh wait, that's...
Sorry.
My Frieza in me is talking.
I forgot Goku cares.
Goku is no match for Raditz overwhelming strength.
And Raditz successfully kidnapped Gohan.
However...
He is then treated to an unexpected reunion.
Piccolo!
Piccolo?
Yeah, Piccolo!
But what are you doing here?
I was pursuing him.
As much as I'd like to kill the wretch myself.
The sad truth is I have a better shot at that.
If you were along for the ride.
Hold on.
You mean team up with me?
Why in the world would you ever do that?
Because I came from the future.
We're gonna be best friends.
This would just be a temporary alliance.
Only for the sake of eradicating that alien off my planet.
Yeah, temporary for like 80 more years, I guess.
Once that purpose has been served, I'll keep my promise to Koshin.
Honestly, he's a better father than Goku could ever be.
I think Goku should not...
Goku...
Oh, wait.
I can work with Piccolo?
Or go at it alone?
Oh my god!
This is like the what-if scenario!
This is the what-if!
I'm gonna do it alone.
I don't...
I wonder what happens if I go alone.
Yeah!
I'm gonna do it alone.
No, don't perpetuate the stereotype.
We don't need you, Piccolo!
We don't need you!
Gohan's gonna recognize me as Piccolo!
This is real father!
Whatever you say.
That's right.
You might have taken my son now!
But...
Goku, watch yourself and keep calm.
We all know you can do this.
Go away!
I'm gonna solo him.
Let me come with you.
The three of us together could whip that guy easy.
Yeah, I don't need Piccolo.
I have fucking Krillin.
I have a human.
But you've already been brought back to life by Shenron once before.
Oh shit.
Goku's like, Krillin, you're gonna fucking die.
I don't wanna do that again.
Maybe so.
But don't let yourself get killed, Goku.
Or we're all dead.
Master Roshi's right.
If I die, you have Piccolo!
Krillin.
Master Roshi.
Gohan is now fatherless.
You're the best.
No.
I'm gonna win this, guys.
I can solo him.
I literally almost killed Raditz.
Also, thank you, Marshall, for vindicating me.
And also, Dango.
Yeah!
Not the tracker.
Piccolo's like the babysitter.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wonder Woman!
Let's follow them!
Bloom, yes, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Fun fact, but in the Dragon Ball Super anime, Goku confirms he never kissed his wife, which can imply he's- No, he has!
Cause, what other Saiyan would it be?!
Like, they're literally half-Saiyan, so like, it had to be him!
So, like, he just...
I don't know.
Hahaha!
I don't know how it happened, but I just I guess I Guess he never kissed it wasn't love
His emotional and mental IQ is definitely not an adult
I don't think he knows how to process the human world
I don't think he knows how to process the human world I don't even think he knows how to tie his shoelace, Raddus.
Please, I don't think Goku can even tie his shoelace.
Like, I don't...
But he's not even wearing shoes!
What am I saying?
He's not even wearing... I don't even think he knows he betrayed anybody!
He's literally not even wearing shoes!
Oh, guys, why didn't I...
Guys, why didn't I ask Goku Piccolo to help?
Guys!
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We'll be fine.
We're gonna be so fine.
We're...
Oh god, okay, we're gonna be... guys, there's no way.
We can't fuck this up.
Oh, I can have Solar Flare!
Oh shit, no, that's not the right move.
I forgot Solar Flare was like Flashbang.
Oh, I bought that ball!
I bought that ball!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, what the fuck?
Why are you so good?
I'm not even wearing shoes!
Nice.
Okay.
Yes!
I got the Solar Flare.
But he jumped?
That should be cheating!
Okay.
Piccolo, why are you watching?
I don't need you, Piccolo!
I don't need you!
I can do this without you!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh shit.
Don't worry, I got this.
See, I'm so much better!
I told you I could solo him!
I don't know what I'm doing, but I knew it!
That's right.
What's going on?
What am I doing?
I did it!
I did
it!
Yeah!
I don't know what I did.
I don't know what I...
Say goodbye, Kakarot!
Wait, what?
But it showed I did it!
Oh shit, crazy Gohan!
How did I level 1,307?
Don't hurt my...
How did I...
How did I win but lose?
Oh yeah, he has a higher power level.
And then I got jealous.
And then I got a better power level after that.
I can't let my son be stronger than me.
Yeah, I was like 1,307?
No, stop!
Don't do it!
Please!
He's just a...
Just a child?
Is that what you were going to say, Kakarot?
Don't worry, brother.
I failed the what if?
In the next world!
I didn't win fast enough!
But he was so strong!
No!
Oh, thank God, I'm going to die.
Maybe I can play Vegeta.
It's the only way to beat you!
Sorry to keep you waiting.
No!
Not the cannon event!
Do it!
No!
Stop!
Special beam cannon!
I just threw a fucking...
Oh shit!
Okay, goodbye.
It's alright, we'll just find the Dragon Balls for the, like, 150th time.
Wait,
what's the alternate event?
You can all go to hell.
Still, I thank you for the information.
Everything that has happened here today...
Wait, R3?
...has been transmitted.
Oh shit!
I'm just like, hey Piccolo, I'm sort of still alive if you want to come over here and...
When they've learned that I've been killed...
I'm still...
I'm still sort of alive, Piccolo, if you want to come over here...
I...
The other...
Two Saiyans...
When...
When will they arrive here?
How long?
One year.
Just one short year.
Prince Vegeta's coming.
Oh no.
My eyes.
Piccolo, please!
Babe, you don't need the Dragon Ball!
Please, Piccolo, take me to the fuck?
Give me the bean!
How sweet is that victory taste now?
They're going to wipe you...
all out.
They'll...
Soon...
Have you...
Give me the Senju Bean, Piccolo!
Do you have the I'm still alive!
Oh shit.
No beats.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, it's already there?
That person, thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
I can't believe I was too slow to unlock the alternate route!
After Goku perishes in the battle with Raditz, as just as Raditz said, within a year, the two Saiyans came to Earth.
Finally, having completed his training on King Kai's planet, Goku is revived by the Dragon Balls and returned once more to the battlefield.
Oh no, the Cybermen.
I heard people are naming Cybermen just to piss people off.
Unable to escape, the Yamcha dies in an explosion induced by the self-destructing weapon, the Saiyans.
Oh my god, Yamcha.
Yamcha, no!
Him and his one fan.
One bi- His one fan with 500 alternate accounts.
Just when all hope seems to be lost, Goku arrives on the scene.
How's it feel, seeing your little friend's corpse has scattered all over?
There was another one, but there's probably not a scrap of him left.
Piccolo's gone.
I say nonchalantly.
What, you gonna- I mean, I'm just like, well, I could just wish him back.
Being dead doesn't even have real consequences anymore to these guys.
They're like, oh, he's dead.
Let me just wish him back to life.
That stupid look on your face just makes me want to kill you faster.
You'll pay for this!
You'll both pay!
You bastards!
Vegeta, what does this power of love for say?
Oh, okay, not yet.
Wait, what do I do?
What?
Oh, this again!
Oh, my god, he set the thing!
Set the thing!
Holy shit, he set the thing, guys!
Hahaha.
That's right, Nappa, get over here.
Get your ass over here.
I know only two moves, and that's enough moves for me.
That's fucking right!
Let's go!
Oh, shit!
Okay, not like that, though.
Oh, nice!
I countered!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
That's fine.
I figured it out.
That's fucking right.
Soul Affair!
I'm so great!
Okay.
Oh, what's that?
What's that?
What's he doing?
Oh, he missed!
I don't think he missed, though.
Wait, what is he doing?
What is that?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, that dot!
No!
I didn't know what he's doing!
Okay, that's fine.
Me and my two moves!
Square, square, triangle!
It has not failed me yet!
Triangle time!
Oh, shit!
He's slapping them away!
He's charging.
Oh, he's charging!
We did it!
The two moves!
I did it!
Yeah, that's Vegeta's technique!
I only know Vegeta's technique!
Square, square...
Square, square, square, triangle!
Do you know how to use your I.A.M.
specials?
Vegeta!
No!
Weak!
I'm sorry, Nappa.
I have no use for a paralyzed Saiyan!
Oh, shit!
Vegeta, that's fucked!
You're dead white!
Oh!
Vegeta!
Just don't get paralyzed!
It's that easy!
He's a psycho!
He just killed his own partner for no reason!
This is the Saiyan way, Krillin!
You don't understand!
Weakness is not allowed in the Saiyans!
Now he's just dead.
I thought Vegeta was your favorite and that's why I...
You saw what that other Saiyan can do?
If we stick around, we'll only be getting in your dad's way!
Sorry, Gohan.
This guy's stronger than I thought he'd be.
Yeah?
And?
What?
Did I say it?
I'm not good at doing this.
Okay, I can't do this anymore.
This is gonna be too much.
Okay, that's not it.
I'm done.
I'm done!
He literally blew up planets, so like, that's all I'm saying.
He did change.
Every once in a while, they would do an episode where they're like, Vegeta suddenly turns evil.
And like, turns evil again.
You should feel lucky.
Not every low class warrior gets the chance to spar with a super elite like myself.
Not long after Saiyans are born, their skills as a soldier are tested.
The scum whose scores are ranked the lowest are sent to the outer worlds.
Doesn't turn evil, he just doesn't care.
Isn't that worse?
That's... isn't that just like... being a psychopath when they don't care?
I think it is worse.
You don't get it.
I can fix him.
Yes.
And as a result, I was lucky enough to come here to Earth.
I'm grateful for that.
Besides, even a lower class outcast can surpass an elite if he puts his mind to it.
Yeah.
Practice makes perfect.
Determination, Vegeta.
I didn't get handed everything to me.
You're just a spoiled little brat.
You have a fucking silver spoon stuck in your ass.
Now let me show you a wall that you will never have the ability to scale through ever alone.
Oh shit, is this when he turns into a giant monkey?
I'm sorry.
I know I should stop saying monkey.
I'm so sorry.
Doki, no!
Okay.
Wait a minute, spoiler.
I fucking watched the show.
Don't worry, I will use your moves against you!
My square-square-triangle move will never fail me!
That's fucking right!
Triangle!
Yes!
Don't worry!
Butch, don't know how to counter this!
Butch, sorry.
Oh shit.
Oh, Galaga.
No.
Oh god.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
How do I...
No, I can't dodge that!
Oh no, he's coming in.
No!
There we go, I got him.
Bro, you're blocking?
Who the fuck taught you how to block?
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
Try that again, bitch.
That's right.
Try that.
Oh, you're gonna keep blocking?
Try that again.
Oh shit, he didn't try.
Look at that.
That's fucking right.
Oh wait, he's still trying to...
Alright, don't worry, I can do that.
Do I keep doing that?
That's right.
Oh.
JK.
There we go.
That's right.
Oh!
Yeah, that's right!
Do it again!
Oh, bitch!
Oh no!
No!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Ha ha ha!
That's okay.
Fucking didn't learn.
And the cheese.
He's getting cooked.
Lexi.
Oh, I saw that episode!
I saw that!
I remember cause I like the ocean dub.
I thought it was really interesting.
Lexi.
They give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, now.
Now... then what?
Okay, what is like... I just called him a giant... giant... okay, ape?
Is that better?
I'm sorry.
Vegeta was hit.
Goku can still sense a trace of his ki-chi remaining.
Yajirobe... oh my god, Yajirobe sounds like that guy from regular show.
Emerged from his hiding place, but Goku instructs him to flee.
Sure enough, Vegeta rises once more.
Ready?
To... challenge Goku again.
Goku believes his only chance for victory is to use the Spirit Bomb.
Yeah, he sounds like Muscle Man.
However, Vegeta has a secret technique known only to Saiyans up to his sleeves.
What was that?
Oh!
It's time!
He's gonna turn into a giant ape!
Guys, I went to my HR sensitivity training class.
That Frieza put me through.
Because the Frieza army is filled with Saiyans, I had to go to sensitivity training.
And now I know that we have to call them Great Apes.
This is not fair!
He's like... six times my size!
He turned into a giant monkey!
Okay!
So, Goku...
Oh, just cause he's... okay.
Oh, hey, Muscle Man.
He can say it!
The only choice now is to gather energy from all over the Earth!
To make a Spirit Bomb!
It's the same thing, Doki.
There's nothing completely new about this!
It's a ghost!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
What the fuck?!
Hada, what the fuck?
Oh my g I can't even...
Oh, I can't...
Like, what do I look at?!
HAHAHA!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Like, what the fuck do I even look at?!
Like, holy fuck!
Like, I don't even... what the fuck?!
Oh my god, everything!
I'm looking at his fucking crotch.
Bro, like, this is bullshit!
Like, oh my... no, what?
I'm just gonna punch him in the fucking crotch, I guess.
Like...
Wait, did I?
Oh, I dodged?
Nice.
Oh shit.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please!
No wonder!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god!
Bro!
I'm just... I'm so confused!
I'm so confused!
Wait, they're not... No!
I have vacancy!
Oh my god!
Okay, alright.
This is... goodbye.
Is this a what if?
Well, and then I guess we lost.
With all the remaining warriors of Earth also defeated, the planet comes after... comes under Vegeta's tyrannical control.
Okay, am I retry on normal?
Okay, I'm on normal.
Oh my god!
What the...
No!
It was me!
Yeah!
You're a monster!
Oh shit!
Wait, can I just do this?
That's good.
Oh my god!
I... Oh!
Shit!
No!
Goku, if you die, everything is over!
Please!
I might as well be done!
Oh my god!
I can't... I can't...
This guy... No wonder... Oh my... Okay, now I understand why so many people... How do I...
How do I do anything?
Jesus Christ!
I'm just going full power spamming.
If you don't, you literally... What the...
What the fuck is that bullshit?
Oh my god, Vegeta.
This is why I wish I was playing Vegeta.
This is exactly why.
Okay, we'll try that.
How do I... Okay.
Okay, retry.
Oh my god.
Guys, okay.
Explanation of controls.
Okay, alright.
R2 square.
Okay, we got this.
Okay, fly time.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I can't even get up.
Please.
No!
Let me fly!
Get me out of here!
Get in!
Oh my god!
Get in here!
I'll see you in the next one!
There's no way!
At least I'll get to apologize to you!
Kamehameha!
Get out!
That's right.
Oh shit, I'm sorry!
Me first.
Oh, you're a fucker.
You're actually a fucker.
No!
He got me down!
He swatted me like a fucking fly!
Holy shit!
You're not supposed to do that!
Oh my god!
Guys, what do you mean I have to attack him after?
Oh my god, I'm trying to!
No!
Okay, don't worry.
There we go.
Don't worry.
He can't get to me now.
Oh shit, he got to me now!
He got to me now!
Jesus Christ!
Did I do it?
I did it!
Wait, did I do it?
Am I dead?
Oh, I'm dead.
Never mind.
I didn't do it.
I didn't do it!
Why did I make a good sound?
Like why?
He like made a good sound.
Yeah, so I thought I did it.
Guys, I didn't do it.
Oh my god, please, please, you're so...
Please, I'm, I'm, please!
Holy shit, please!
I need to beat this guy.
No matter what.
Oh my god, please!
Every ounce of my energy.
For the tiny chance of a victory.
Me first.
If I die, I'll see you in the next one.
No, no!
Okay, nice.
That's fucking right.
And then, charge!
Kamehameha!
That's fucking right!
What are you gonna do, huh?
No, stop!
Shit!
Oh!
Oh, I missed!
No!
I'm dead.
Wait, I can get it first.
I can get it first.
Oh, he fucking blocked it!
You're such a little bitch!
No.
Oh, no.
No, please!
I swear I dodged!
No!
I'm gonna head to the tail.
Where's the tail?
Give me the tail!
No!
Jesus Christ!
What?
Oh, god!
Bro, we're gonna be here forever!
What?
Oh!
This giant fucking ape!
We're gonna be here fucking forever!
Jesus!
Okay.
What?
I totally blocked!
This is bullshit!
This is Vegeta propaganda!
No matter what!
Oh my god, please!
I'll have to use every ounce of my energy!
Please!
Oh my god!
For the tiniest chance of victory!
Oh, nice!
If I die...
I'm too fucking low!
I'll see you in the next one!
At least I'll get to apologize to you!
Fuck you!
I'll shoot you in the fucking crotch if I have to!
That's fucking right!
You think I won't?
Yeah!
Oh, come on!
No!
I'll burn you!
Please stop breaking...
No!
What is this?
Guys...
Oh my god!
Nice!
No!
This is bullshit!
Please stop breaking me!
Oh my god!
Why would they put this in the beginning?
I...
Why would they...
Why would they put this in the fucking beginning?
Guys, give me a sec.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
Let me look at this real quick.
Okay.
R2.
Dragon Dash.
Okay.
Quick Descent.
Zeep.
Okay.
R2.
Dragon Dash.
Okay.
Oh my god!
To break me!
Bro!
This is...
This is so fucked!
This is actually...
This is actually so fucked!
Like...
How?!
Actually!
Okay.
Hold.
Smash attack.
Rush.
Chain.
Action.
The PP is raining.
All right.
Rush.
T.
Okay.
Key.
Dash.
Smash.
Key.
They're all just triangle!
This is fucking...
Okay.
Guard.
Break.
Okay.
Here we go.
This is it.
I figured it out.
Guys.
The one thing.
I did it.
That's fucking right.
It was me!
I figured!
It's over.
It's... oh shit, it's not over.
It's not... oh, no.
No, it's not over!
Oh, shit!
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys, it's not over anymore.
You can't get to me.
I'm in the... I have the fucking rock.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
That's... oh, I'm fucking... okay.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
No, this is not fine.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, he's charging.
No!
He grabbed me!
No.
Please stop.
Please.
Please stop breaking.
Please stop breaking!
That was the closest.
That was the closest I have.
That was literally... oh, my God.
I keep getting grabbed.
Oh, the crap.
Okay, this is it.
I figured it out.
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's fine.
What?
This is... bro!
Bro!
What do I do?
Like, oh...
Oh, my God.
Please.
I swear to God.
Oh, no.
That's holding back!
Okay.
Nice.
No!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm trying.
I won.
What?
He dies!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I can't.
I'm trying my best to go up.
Go up!
Go, go!
It's the only way!
No!
Oh, God.
You guys.
Please.
Oh, my God.
My God.
Please.
Okay.
Stop!
Please, stop!
Break!
Yes!
Please!
PLEASE!
I'll use this!
OH MY GOD!
I'M SO MAD!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
No!
Please!
Please, Goku!
I beg of you!
AHHHH!
I can't!
I... I... I can't!
Please stop!
Please!
NO!
Okay.
Just... keep going up!
Keep going up!
OH SHIT!
STOP!
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW ME!
I...
After all this time?
After...
Yes!
Yes, Goku!
After all my... I fucking hate him!
I hate him so much!
How do I grab his tail?!
HOW?!
I'm literally in his body right now!
What do I press?!
Hand it over!
OH MY GOD!
You don't!
Okay... that's...
Leave me ALONE!
I need to beat this guy.
Oh please...
I'm going to use every ounce of my energy...
...for the tiniest chance...
...at victory!
The tiniest chance.
Is this?
Here we go.
Alright, this is so sad.
That is the saddest thing I saw today.
Oh my god, I fucking hate this guy so much!
Please!
Oh my god, you suck!
You suck!
Why are you like this?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Please don't get close to me.
Don't worry, he doesn't care.
No.
Oh, don't worry, the rock did not block me.
Wait, what?!
I didn't see you, you fucker!
Please.
What is he doing?
What is he doing?!
What the fuck is that?!
Yalikun!
Bro!
We do not need a Yalikun!
He literally...
Oh my god.
Bro!
He...
Oh hey, my proficiency went up!
That...
That was...
That was so disrespectful.
That...
Oh my god, please, no!
Stop.
Stop!
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
Yes, it was.
It was you!
Oh my god.
In 20 years, one day.
Guys, in 20 years.
Cheers!
We'll know what it's like.
Well, no.
It's fine, me too.
Oh god, no.
Oh, that's fine.
No!
Whoa!
Kamehameha!
Oh god, no!
Nope.
Oh god.
I'm trying to block!
Stop!
Guys, it's very rude for you to...
It's very rude!
He can aim up!
Okay, I didn't realize he can aim up.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Goodbye.
Get over there.
Get over here.
Get over...
No!
Fuck!
I don't know why I did that!
I felt so cocky!
Whoa!
Here we go.
I'll get it first!
That's fucking...
Oh, it doesn't matter if I get it first, though.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
He can do that?!
He can do that too?!
Guys, I...
There's no way.
There's no way!
Oh my god!
Okay.
After all this time, I get it!
Don't worry, he can shoot through that!
Guys, he shot through that!
Guys, I can't believe Rock doesn't block me from that!
I can't believe!
I owe this to you, Graves!
Okay.
No matter what!
Okay, there we go.
Don't worry, I got you.
Every ounce of my energy!
Here I go!
For the tiniest chance!
There we go!
It didn't do anything!
That's fine!
I'll see you in the next one!
At least I'll get to apologize to you!
That's fine!
My...
I... Oh, that's fine!
He walked into it like a little bitch!
Scotty!
Don't fail me now!
Where am I?
Oh, fuck!
What?!
Okay!
That's fine!
Okay.
That's okay.
Here we go.
That's fine!
I can do this!
I cannot!
Okay!
There's the other one?
What's the other one?
Oh, that!
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait, what's...
This way!
Oh, god!
It's fine!
It's not fine!
I'm so weak!
I can't hear you!
Guys, this is my first...
My first Dragon Ball Z fighting game!
Please!
Kamehameha!
No, it's okay.
Not nice.
Let me fly!
Okay.
Whoa!
I can keep charging!
That should be...
Oh!
You're such a fucker!
I am trying!
He's always a fucking fly!
He likes to fly!
I'm trying to see!
Look at him!
He comes back up like a little bitch!
He just...
He just likes to fly!
I can't stop him from that!
I can't stop this!
Look!
He's flying!
Like... I'm...
This is as high as I could go!
This is as high as I can literally go!
This is...
Literally!
He just keeps getting higher!
He...
All he wants to do is just kill me!
Okay.
That's fine.
No!
Okay.
Get out of here!
I'm trying my best to be above him!
But all he wants to do is just fly up!
He's...
He just wants to keep flying!
Please!
Don't get close to me!
Please get away!
No!
Ah!
And with that, I lost the majority of my HP!
What was that?
And this is how I lost it all!
It was just that easy!
It was that easy!
All it took was one hit!
All it took was one fucking...
One fucking hit!
Oh my god!
This is it!
Please!
Don't get near me!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
Oh my god!
One HP in a dream!
Let's go!
We did it!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it!
It's Spirit Bomb time!
Solar Flare!
By the time he needs!
Goku uses...
I wish this was more cinematic for this.
It's not a screenshot.
Goku uses his Solar Flare.
Or have narration.
Then makes a run for it.
Getting as far as he can.
Okay, I think I put enough distance between us.
I wish they used like the classic like the Dragon Ball Z narrator.
To gather the little key from all the living creatures on Earth to fire one shot in the hopes of turning things around.
Mack!
Thank you for the five gifted ships!
Thank you!
Coward!
Where are you?
I am the cinematic!
Time's up!
He found me!
There!
It's done!
I've gathered energy from every corner of the world!
Now!
Take this!
Oh wait, no!
He passed away?
That's sad.
I didn't know the narrator passed away.
Mori, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Dragons of the chat, lend Doki your bow!
Raise your arms up, chat!
Give me your powers!
Consider that a little farewell present.
I don't have the strength to lift a finger.
So just do what you're gonna do to me, alright?
Take your best shot!
Yeah, pussy.
Do it.
Damn you, Kakarot!
How dare you leave a scar on my beautiful face!
I was gonna...
Oh Vegeta, you're not... It's just on your fucking ape face.
It's on your human face.
Or sorry, Saiyan face.
Oh shit!
Oh!
Hey look!
If two Saiyans turn into a giant ape, you can technically say he's the hottest ape around.
Bro, it's taking forever to crush him.
Every bone in your body breaking must hurt!
I think your friends are here.
How quaint!
Gohan!
You put my dad down right now!
I can't believe he became an office worker.
He became...
He became a salaryman after all that.
Yajirobe, who has been waiting for the right moment to attack, leaps out and slices off the great ape's Vegeta tail.
Go Yajirobe!
Vegeta returns to his regular form.
However, Goku remains incapacitated and not a Krillin nor Gohan stand a chance against even a weakened Vegeta.
Calling Krillin to his side, Goku entrusts him with the spirit bomb.
All that's left is to wait for it on the opening... Guys!
Raise your hands!
This is it!
I know it's for Krillin but like, he's the best we can do!
I know you wanted to give your spirit bomb to Goku and we're now giving it to his like, to a bootleg version of him, but raise your hands!
I fucking was so mad!
No choice now!
I can't!
The muscle man!
Krillin's win count!
Whoa!
He missed?
With the power of hope and determination!
My son!
Oh my god!
Gohan!
Vegeta survives the spirit bomb!
And he's naked!
He's a naked...
I'm trying not to say the M word.
But he's a naked giant ape.
My sensitivity training in HR has taught me that only Saiyans can say that.
Krillin's just about to finish Vegeta off once and for all when Goku stops him.
Now where the existence of Planet Namek, Krillin, Gohan, and Bulma believe it may hold a new set of Dragon Balls.
The ape!
As Goku needs more time to recuperate the three set off.
I'm trying not to say, you know, the chimpanzee word.
Chimpanzees with tails!
I can't say that!
It's not good!
That's a freeze!
If you say chimpanzee with tail word, that makes you like Frieza.
And that's not good.
Chimpanzee is worse?
How are they worse?
They're literally smarter than monkeys!
I'm so sorry if I offend anyone.
I'm so sorry.
It's true!
Chimpanzees are smarter than monkeys!
After about one month after the group set off on their journey, Goku receives an SOS from planet Namek.
We're not monkeys!
Monkeys are different!
They have tails!
Okay, apes and monkeys, the difference between gorillas, chimpanzees, and monkeys is that gorillas and chimpanzees don't have tails.
And like, monkeys have tails!
On the spaceship, Goku continues because Frieza uses it derogatory against Saiyans.
You need to chill out!
A newly recovered Vegeta also arrives, hoping to lay his hands on the very same Dragon Balls.
To get their strong!
Gamer, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Toki, I worshipped you!
I'll pay you ten dollars to stop digging the hole!
And Tom, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Vegeta may have in response, but she just seemed to team up with Krillin.
Oh my god, these cut- they're so fa- The Ginyu Forces!
I love the Ginyu Forces!
They skipped so much!
Yeah, they did!
How did we get here?
How the fuck did we get here?
Look, you guys have got a choice to make here!
Hey, Toki, I just bought you a shovel!
Please keep going!
Toki, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Either get off this planet and go home, or you're gonna wind up like your friend here!
Did you hear that, Bertha?
I forgot that's his voice!
This goat knocks a raccoon with a lucky shot!
And suddenly, he's dishing out threats to the likes of us!
Gorilla, gorilla, gorilla!
Tom, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I forgot he's Australian!
I forgot most of the Ginyu Forces are Australian.
The Space Australians.
That's why they're in Frieza's army!
They're criminals!
Don't worry, I learned...
Even though I learned how to actually play the game, I'm gonna do my favorite move.
Triangle, triangle, triangle!
It has always worked!
That's right!
Now that you're tiny, I can do my favorite move!
I didn't learn!
Wait, can I...
That's fucking right!
I don't need to learn!
Oh shit!
Maybe I do!
Maybe...
Maybe I actually do need to learn.
No!
At best I'll use the Kamehameha!
Oh shit!
What?
That fucking tracks me?
Oh!
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
That's fine.
I have so much HP.
Like...
That's so fine.
We don't need to breathe water.
Oh shit.
Don't make me use the circle on you just like how I used it on Vegeta.
Don't fucking make me use it.
That's fucking right.
We don't need to breathe water.
We're Saiyans.
Why is Goku green?
Is he stupid?
Yay!
So easy.
And we did it!
All me!
Goku swiftly overpowers two members of the Ginyu forces.
After he manages to escape, but Goku has more than demonstrated the fruits of his training.
He hears about the Dragon Ball from Gohan and the others.
But before they can take action, Goku senses a strong ki headed to the direction of Guru.
Goku tells the others to head straight for the Dragon Balls where he readies himself once more.
It's time for him to put an end to Ginyu.
No!
Not Captain Ginyu!
He's so cool!
So this is the guy, huh?
His power level is only around 5,000.
That's him, Captain.
Don't be fooled.
This freak's way stronger than that.
Am I in a new timeline?
How did I get in?
He must be capable of boosting his strength in the midst of combat.
From what I can tell, I'd say his true power level is somewhere around 60,000.
60,000?
But that can't be!
Oh, is he gonna go, I wanna be a fry!
It's not unheard of.
He could have a natural talent, or perhaps his abilities have been amplified by a mutation like us.
Either way, this battle's sure to be interesting.
I already fixed him?
I fucking knew it, guys.
Bulma was right.
You can fix masked criminals.
You can't fix masked murderers, guys.
As long as you're hot enough.
Oh, shit.
Okay, um, oh, oh.
Guys, guys, please.
Guys, guys.
Guys, oh, shit!
I don't want the- guys!
Guys!
Guys, I don't- I don't wanna- I don't wanna be in this timeline anymore, guys!
I don't- Guys, I don't wanna be in this timeline anymore, guys!
Guys, this timeline fucking sucks, guys!
This timeline fucking sucks!
Bulma.
Oh my god.
What?
Yeah, he doesn't need help!
Look at him!
He's so okay!
He's- he's so okay, guys!
Oh.
Don't worry!
Look at that!
He's so healthy!
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, don't worry.
There we go.
What's going on?
Did I do it?
Oh, shit!
No, I'm gonna be a frog!
No, don't turn me into a frog!
Don't turn me into you, and then turn me into a frog!
No, I don't wanna change!
Nooo!
I don't wanna change!
Then he lets out a definite scream.
And then he changes a technique that enables him to switch bodies with Goku.
Now in control of Goku's body, Captain Ginyu heads back to his spaceship with his subordinate.
Goku makes a desperate chase after them, but is hindered, trapped in Captain Ginyu's injured body.
Guys, listen!
That's not me!
Using my body!
The others arrive to find Goku battling his own body.
Unknown to everyone, Vegeta has his own plans for Ginyu, but first...
...
Seeing that Birda has lost his will to fight, Vegeta ruthlessly puts an end to his life.
Okay, why are you questioning?
Yeah, I was gonna be like, bro, this is another Saturday for Vegeta!
He literally blew up planets!
He killed children!
You think he cares at this point?!
After finishing off Birda, Vegeta shifts his attention to Ginyu, who has taken over Goku's body.
He literally killed children!
He doesn't care!
He doesn't even care!
He doesn't feel anything, guys.
Like, it's not that he likes it.
He doesn't even feel anything.
He's just like, okay.
No!
Goku rushes to intercept Ginyu's body change.
And is able to reclaim his own body just in the nick of time.
Yeah!
Oh no, it's frog time.
Frog time!
Vegeta, dodge!
Goku throws the frog between the Captain and Vegeta.
Oh my god, this is like...
I feel like I'm getting spark notes to game right now.
Like, everything is so fast!
I feel like it's literally like spark notes.
Captain Ginyu is now trapped inside a frog, and Goku is saved.
Goku is then put inside a medical machine to recover.
However, he can sense... Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's Frieza!
My hero!
Meanwhile, Vegeta and the others sense an immense power coming from their opponent.
One that far exceeds their own.
Just as he is marveling at Frieza's strength, Goku treatments finishes, and he is fully healed.
When Goku arrives at the raging battle, Vegeta is moments away from death at Frieza's hands.
I'm begging you, please, beat him for me!
For the pride of our race!
You must defeat him!
Please, he must die by a Saiyan's hand!
And so the battle between Goku and Frieza begins.
Oh, I'm talking about Vegeta!
He's my...
Okay, maybe not.
I forgot he's also a murderer.
I forgot my whole spiel about him murdering children.
Alright, in the end...
In the end, Mr. Satan is my hero.
It's time for me to share my pride.
Pride in myself.
I am a Saiyan that was raised on planet Earth.
All we know is that Mr. Satan is the...
is the...
is the universe's hero.
I will defeat you!
Goku is just trying to take Mr. Satan's credit.
And I would just love to see you try.
I love Frieza's voice actor though.
It just fits so well.
Where the fuck did they come from?
They felt like they were never in the story.
I know they were in the original manga.
Don't listen to that Goku propaganda.
Mr. Satan is my hero!
Yeah, I'm like, where the fuck did...
I was like, where the...
Oh!
I was supposed to know!
It's never gave me shit like this before!
Like, how?
How was I supposed to know I had to do a fucking quick time event?
How?
I thought I just had to mash until I didn't have to mash again.
Oh my god, is he...
Is he gonna come over?
Why aren't you a gamer?
Sometimes I don't know!
Okay.
Don't worry, I can keep doing this forever.
Now that I learned the cheese...
Now that I learned the cheese, it's fine.
Oh shit, he's coming closer.
Guys, he's coming closer.
What did I do?
I got excited.
What did I...
What did I fucking do?
Guys, I got so excited.
Oh!
I have to press it again!
Oh, I see!
I thought I could hold it!
I thought I could actually hold it.
I didn't realize like... Okay.
Okay, let's actually fight him.
You have to like, separately press... What the fuck?
Okay, that should be illegal now, dude.
Don't worry.
Yeah, you have to press that separately.
I didn't know... What?
Did he dodge now?
Okay, guys.
I did it too much.
Oh my god.
Guys, I did it too much.
Now he...
Now he knows.
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
Now I have a new strat.
Oh, shit.
Oh, nice.
Guys, I have a new strat now.
Not that he knows my Kamehameha strat.
That's fucking right.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
He banged me!
Okay, we gotta retrap.
Oh, shit.
What?
I pressed R1!
Okay.
Okay, here we go again.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, not figuring it out.
I don't know if I've ever felt this excited about the prospect of battle in my entire life.
Oh my god.
What's new, Frieza?
Okay.
That's fucking right.
No!
Come on.
No, don't.
Please.
That's not cool.
Okay.
Kamehameha time.
Where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
I should hit him, right?
What?
Oh, you're so stupid!
You're so fucking stupid!
I'm coming in the water!
You're so dumb!
Oh my god!
You're so stupid!
Oh, shit.
I'm stupid.
That's right.
You don't need to breathe water.
We don't need to breathe water.
None of us needs it.
That's fucking right.
Get in here.
Get over here.
I'll defeat you in the water.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
Oh.
Is it?
Yes, son!
Wait, guys!
No.
Yes.
Alright.
Again?
Goku, you can't fix everything with Spirit Bomb.
You can't.
Not everything can be fixed with Spirit Bomb, Goku.
Not everything.
Yes, you can.
It's called friendship.
You don't understand, Doki.
I like...
I swear, the Spirit Bomb shit is like his MacGuffin.
If everything fails, we use the Spirit Bomb.
Yes, it is.
Jesus Christ.
Did I hit that?
No way.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Bro, why is he so fucking...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Okay.
No.
Almost got it.
Do I get it?
Yes!
That's fucking right.
Yeah!
Impossible.
This can't be happening to me.
Yeah!
I did it!
Alright, guys.
It's time for the Spirit Bomb.
Again.
It's time for Goku's get out of jail free card.
Is it what it is?
Goku manages to defeat Frieza.
Though by the skin of his teeth, as soon as his feet touch the ground, Gohan and the others cheer, welcoming him back.
Oh, I did the what if!
Let's go home.
Lucky us, my little spaceship should be able to get us back in just under six days.
I keep forgetting to use the Spirit Bomb.
I don't remember how to do it.
Guys, I told you.
I told you!
We don't need to use the Spirit Bomb, chat.
We don't.
We can't just solve everything with a Spirit Bomb.
We have to learn alternate...
We have to learn alternate, like, answers.
Not canon.
Let's go home.
Lucky us, my little spaceship should be able to get us back in under six days.
Heyy!
Wasn't that Kuren?
Oh shit, you're right!
I forgot Bulma's in this part of the story.
Dude, I,
Like, I just stopped hearing about Bulma?
Goku, Bulma's been with us since Dragon Ball.
We did it!
We're gonna... similar with the Dragon Ball... with the... with the...
Similar with the fucking Spirit Bomb.
We're just gonna wish everybody back to life.
Well, I did make him a promise!
Ouch!
Surely Frieza's gonna die-die now.
They don't make evil characters like Frieza anymore.
Like, just... characters that are just evil for the sake of being evil.
That's why Frieza has always been, like, such an interesting character to me.
Frieza and Vegeta.
Vegeta's awesome.
Vegeta's, like, just evil.
I meant, like... I meant, like... I mean, like...
I mean, like, just evil characters for the sake of being evil.
Because a lot of characters now, a lot of villains, are just...
The thing about villains now is that...
No, I'm not... like, that style is, like, you know, like, back then.
But I'm talking about newer villains, like, characters now.
Where they're all, like, redeemable.
Or, like, there's a motive on why they're so evil.
You know, especially, like, Disney characters, too.
They're always, like... they always have, like, characters that are, like...
Oh, there's a reason why I'm evil and you're supposed to feel bad for me.
But, like, I... I wish they were, like...
It just gets so boring.
Because, like, everybody is just...
They just have... they have to be misunderstood or some shit.
Like...
Some people are just fucking bad.
Alright.
Wait.
Can I not start it?
Why won't it let me start it?
No, I don't...
Oh, it's, like, laggy a little bit.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, Scar...
I don't like how Scar has a tragic story...
Backstory now in the live action.
And he's like...
My brother!
And I'm like...
What?
Like...
What was it?
Mufasa is, like, an orphan.
And, like...
He takes over...
Like...
He...
It's just so weird.
They're making...
They're making Lion King 2 live action.
Quote on quote.
Even though it's all CGI.
And then...
Scar is apparently, like...
They gave Scar, like, a happy childhood or whatever.
And, like, how he sees Mufasa is...
It's so weird.
It's such a weird sequel.
Let's get on my spaceship.
Wait.
Are we watching this part again?
Wait, what?
What did I...?
Oh, I fucked up.
Wait, why am I...?
What?
Skip.
Did I press the wrong thing?
Oh, what?
What happened?
Oh!
Guys, I beat the game!
Guys, I did it!
Oh!
I beat the game!
Oh my god!
GG!
I'm so confused!
I have to fucking fight him again?
I
have to do it correctly?
This is correctly!
All I'm saying... Okay, that's bullshit.
All I'm saying is that we can't keep using the Spirit Bomb as a fucking crutch, guys.
Okay.
There we go, I did it, guys.
First try.
Guys, I did it, guys.
Where is he?
I can't even tell where he is.
I'm just in the water.
Where did I go?
He doesn't know where I am.
If I don't know where he is, he doesn't know where I am.
That's how it goes.
What?!
That should be legal!
Oh god.
Where am I?
No.
No way.
No way!
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
I know what to do.
That's fucking right.
Oh, he counters too?
That should be cheating!
Bro, he counters more than me!
It's okay.
I'm in the water.
The water is literally like my... the counter-counter.
What the fuck?!
Do I just keep charging?
Oh shit!
Oh!
Boom!
Boost!
No!
Bang.
Oh, nice.
I dodged it.
That's right.
Bang.
What, bitch?
Again?!
Fucking... Oh my... Okay, we're...
I can't... I can't keep using water as a... I can!
I can!
You don't know that!
Yes, I can!
I don't know if I've ever felt this excited about the prospect of...
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I got him.
If he can use bang, I can use water!
Okay.
God damn it.
Ha!
Alright, nice.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh my god, he punched me through the...
Oh no.
No!
Counter this!
What?!
You can't counter back when I count!
It's time for sudden death!
Oh god, no.
Not again.
Why don't we finish with the...
Alright.
No, not again!
No!
Get me out of the water!
I don't need water as a crutch.
Okay.
Boost!
Did I hit him?
I hit him.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh, he's going in the water!
I didn't want to go to the water!
I'm trying so hard to play outside of the water.
This is his fault.
Oh, please.
No!
How is he stronger?
What the fuck!
How did he get so difficult?
Oh shit.
Nice.
You should max power, then karma.
Okay.
Oh shit.
I didn't even realize he was right in front of me.
I couldn't tell.
Okay.
I'm going to max power too.
Bitch.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Look.
I didn't know he was there.
I didn't.
Oh my god!
I didn't know!
Jesus Christ.
How do you remember the last fight?
Oh my god!
And he fucking...
Your energy, guys!
I'm trying to get excited apparently.
Oh my god!
He actually remembers the fight from before!
I did it!
Okay, I'm fucking powering up.
I got cheesed by... it's not fair!
I'm supposed to cheese the CPU!
That's how it's supposed to go!
I'm literally the main character!
I got revived 200 times!
What is that?!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck is going on?!
Goddamn!
Why can't I do that?!
All I'm saying is, why can't I do that?!
I don't want to be able to do that!
I'm alive in the vacuum of space!
But can you?
I don't know.
Now perish along with this planet!
Oh my g- Okay.
Okay, okay, Frieza, I get it.
I get it, Frieza.
I- I- I get it.
I- I get it, Frieza.
Oh my god, Frieza, please!
Frieza, please!
I'm sorry!
I didn't realize me beating that game that one time!
Me beating that game that one time messed everything up!
Oh shit!
Nice!
I did it!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Now I'm gonna spam this now!
Where am I?
Where- Okay, I don't think that worked, guys.
I- New combo!
Holy shit!
Wait, I'm gonna die!
Here we go.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
But it's fine.
It's- It's so not fine, guys.
It's definitely not fine!
I don't feel good right now.
I'm literally, like, one hit away.
I'm one HP right now!
We're not okay, guys!
Oh god.
He doesn't know!
The AI doesn't know!
That's right!
The AI knows!
The AI knows, guys!
There we go.
No!
Wait, I've never seen what happens when I die.
I never- What happens.
Mission complete.
He knows.
I can't believe the AI learns.
What happens?
After Goku is defeated by a terrifyingly powerful Frieza...
Frieza steals the Dragon Balls and makes his wish.
What does he wish for?
His name reverberates throughout this universe and every creature comes to him known as the Immortal Emperor.
Oh, okay.
That makes sense, you know?
There we go.
That's fine.
I am- I- Please!
I'm using a different move now.
That's right!
I'm boosted!
New combo!
New attack!
I bet you never expected that, Frieza!
I bet you never expected that!
Oh, shit.
No!
The Reverse Spirit Bomb!
The Evil Bomb!
The Anti-Spirit Bomb!
No!
I wanna know how to do that!
The Reverse Spirit Bomb!
Okay.
That's fine.
That's- Yeah, I fucking- Oh, no!
The Double Counter!
Nice.
Oh, shit!
No!
I'm trying to block, but it's too late!
He's just- Oh, I didn't- No, I didn't do it!
No!
Again?!
The Death- No!
No!
Oh, my God!
He took so much HP!
He took- Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Okay, I failed the Quick Time.
How is he harder?!
How did I get that other alternate ending?!
Like, how- How did I do it?!
Oh, my God!
I don't even- How did I do it?!
I don't even know how I did it last time!
Oh, my God!
How did I do it?!
How- How- How did I do it?!
How- Oh, my God!
Is it because of the Kamehameha?!
Did I use the- The Vegeta Strat on him?!
And then...
I was able to cheese him?!
Oh, I was!
Oh, it was!
That's how I did it!
It's okay, I learned.
I learned.
That's right!
That's- Oh, he fucking- WHAT?!
Boost, he can't do it again!
That's fucking ra- I saw you!
I knew you couldn't do it again!
I knew- I knew you couldn't do it again, you bitch!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
What you gonna do?!
I'm on the skybox!
Yeah!
That's right!
You can't even get here!
That's fucking right!
Oh, my God!
Look at you!
Can't even fly up here!
That's fucking- Oh, he's getting higher!
He's getting higher!
That's right!
I was really hoping I wouldn't have to rely on this again!
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
How do I- I'm gonna win this fight!
My only choice is to gather enough energy for a spirit bomb!
Spirit bomb!
Give me your energy!
No!
Oh, no!
Oh, my God!
I couldn't do it!
Guys, I couldn't do it!
Oh, my God!
Spirit bomb!
Oh!
I can't move!
It won't let me move!
What the fuck?!
Share your energy with me!
It's okay, I'm in the water!
Spirit bomb!
Done!
Here!
How do I recover?
Did it hit?
I did it!
The water!
The underwater spirit bomb!
I do it!
I do the water!
The water straw will fucking come and collect me!
I'm in the water!
I fucking do it!
It is 9999 damage!
Holy shit!
I knew it!
The cannon is restored.
Goku's spirit bomb has finally brought an end to the long and hard-fought battle.
At least our heroes can rest, or so they think, until...
No.
Please, I'm alive!
Yo, I pressed all the buttons.
I literally pressed all the buttons!
Please!
Please, I can't watch this.
Bro,
we can just wish him back, Goku!
We can literally just wish him back!
Why are you so scared?
I mean, to be fair, watching one of your best friends die in front of you is pretty traumatizing, though.
Oh, he doesn't know that yet.
Super Saiyan!
I forgot they don't know yet.
But we could be like, can I have an alternate version of Krillin in my tower?
There's the timeline.
There's the loophole.
Overcome with pure rage at seeing Krillin die before his very eyes, Goku transforms into a legendary Super Saiyan!
Once again, the trumpets of battle sound.
Frieza, whose whole body can survive even the vacuum of space, has decided to launch an attack powerful enough to destroy Planet Namek in its entirety.
I like how it's like... it's like a journalist that's following them around.
Within five minutes left until extinction, Frieza finally reaches full power.
Like, there's some fucking, like, war journalist that's going around taking pictures of this.
Five minutes equals ten episodes.
King Kai!
This is an AP-reported live from Planet Namek.
Oh yeah, the five minute.
We have five minutes left, guys!
Guys, this is gonna be a ten-part game playthrough series.
Of this one fight.
Krillin can't be brought back to life with the Dragon Balls a second time!
He fucking un-actuallyed me!
Krillin was my best friend!
He's like, you stupid fucking streamer!
You fake fan!
Well, like, Frieza has killed a lot of people, Goku.
I don't know if you know this, but Frieza is an incredibly evil person.
Krillin be like, Pop, Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
I know you want the same thing.
You're itching to see what your 100% full power is capable of.
Yeah, but the people he killed weren't his friends, so it was different.
He's part of the problem.
Oh, he's buff-freezing now, I forgot!
Oh my god, can I just, like, do that this entire time?
Can I do this?
You're just gonna keep talking!
The Super Kamehameha!
Kamehameha!
He just dodged it!
Guys, he just... what is he doing?
He just dodged it like it was nothing!
Like, he just... he saw it from... like...
Oh shit!
Oh, I didn't realize he was, like, trying to shoot me.
Oh, I didn't...
Oh, his attacks are so tiny that I can't even see it!
Oh no.
It's my turn.
My turn, bitch!
Oh, okay, it's your turn.
Now it's...
Don't worry, when...
Don't worry, when it's my turn...
Don't worry, it's gonna be my turn soon, right?
Okay.
Oh shit, he can do that?
Okay, don't worry, I got this, too.
What the fuck?
No, I'm trying to block!
What?
That doesn't count as...
Oh, now I'm angry.
Oh my gosh, let me go!
Fuck, he doesn't even remember people's names, that's so fucked.
Where is he?
Oh no, this... oh no, not the disc, not the disc, not the disc, no!
No!
What's going... okay.
I can't!
He's so... he's so buff!
He's so... I'm trying!
I'm trying!
He's so buff!
He's... he's... he's...
Oh yeah.
Jesus Christ, how much... how much did I use there?
Guys, this is what it was supposed to do.
This is what it was supposed to happen if he didn't fucking dodge.
Like, this is...
This is... this is... that's what it was supposed to happen if he didn't fucking dodge there.
Like...
Oh God, please.
METER SMASH!
Oh, I kicked him!
Oh God.
Please!
Get me out of here!
I'll never forgive you!
That's... I know, that's what I was thinking!
I was like...
Where am I?
Did I hit him?
How did I not hit that?
Okay, don't worry, I'm getting angry.
Wait, what?
I get my first, right?
Yes, I get it first!
I get it first, guys!
I can do it again!
Oh shit, I can't.
Wait... he's just trying to stop it!
He's learning!
He's actually learning!
How?
You're AI.
No!
Oh God.
Oh God, it's okay.
Oh my God, where... where... where is he?
Don't make me... don't make me fly up!
I swear to God!
Okay...
He's learning and I'm not!
I'm not!
It's not fair!
He's learning, but I don't know how to learn!
Here we go.
Are you just gonna keep talking?
That's fine.
You know what... you know what time it is.
You know what time it is, guys.
You know...
Guys...
You know what time it is.
Oh shit, he's learning!
Must save space!
Frieza, no!
That's... that's my sea spy!
Holy shit!
Yeah, but like, I'm higher now.
What?
How do I dodge that?
Okay.
Oh my God, he actually...
Oh my God, what?
Here.
Oh my God, please.
Please!
Please don't make that wish!
How?!
Goku!
He wasn't even that far!
How do you miss?
Goku, please!
I don't... I don't understand how you miss!
Oh my...
That's the worst part!
I like, literally don't understand!
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Oh my...
There we go.
Oh my God.
Now I'm angry!
That's it!
There's no way!
This has to hit!
There's no way he dodges this!
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I fucking did it!
Yay!
We did it!
Oh my God!
We fucking did it!
Oh, the irony.
He who triumphs loses everything, while the vanquished escapes.
Talking about me?
I hate to gloat, but there's a lesson here on the virtue of mercy.
Its only value is to your foe!
We'll see about that!
We did it!
In five minutes, guys!
I told you we can beat him in five minutes!
The longest five minutes of my life!
Oh shit, he's Anki!
He's so Anki!
Oh my god, our first cinematic!
Oh, that's it!
Oh my god, did you guys see that?
After a desperate struggle, he's set to life!
The spaceship he's found is too damaged to be piloted.
Luckily, he spies a pod piloted by a ginyu force.
And with that, he nearly escapes.
Planet Namek!
The pod is not headed for Earth.
It's destined for planet Yardrat.
And Goku learns a new technique.
Did you see that?
We did it, guys!
Oh, is it Android Cell Arc?
Oh my god, my favorite arc!
It's not because of Android 18.
One year has passed since the battle of Frieza on planet Namek.
Frieza has survived and comes to Earth seeking revenge.
However, a mysterious young man suddenly appears for him.
It's Trunks!
How did blue and black hair turn into purple hair?
A young man, Dan, transformed into a Super Saiyan just like Goku.
And annihilates Frieza instantly.
Yet at the same time, Goku, who is on planet Yardrat, after escaping from planet Namek, returns to Earth.
The youth tells Goku that his name is Trunks and he has come from the future.
The juice has arrived!
Little Steve, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Apparently in the future, Trunks' friends have been murdered.
And Goku...
By the way, like, when...
This is so fast, like, the little sentences sometimes.
Because it goes on automatically if you saved it for too long.
Like, right now.
Sorry, I was just trying to talk to my chat game.
After telling Goku that he'll come to their aid when the androids arrive, Trunks returns to his own time.
They call him the what?!
Goku is determined to fight alongside his friends to avert the coming catastrophe in their future.
Piccolo, what do you say?
Want to train with me and Gohan?
I've been raring to fight you again.
Okay, I'm pretty sure, like, Goku is stronger now.
Sounds good to me.
Krillin, what about the rest of you guys?
Thanks, but I want to get to Master Roshi's and train with him, actually.
Oh!
He doesn't think you're a good teacher, Goku!
Well, okay!
Oh, there's Yamcha, the useless guy.
Why are you here?
He's like, they're dead.
Like, he...
The years pass, and the fated day of May 12th has finally come.
Goku and the others gather at a time and place that Trunks gave them.
Guys, if all the Yamcha fans suddenly sent anti-me, I wouldn't even notice.
Because it would be just, like, one hate mail.
Hahaha!
Goku and others couldn't even sense the androids before they started landing in the streets.
Suddenly, Goku senses that Yamcha's heat is rapidly fading.
They arrive to find him barely alive, having suffered a mortal blow!
Oh, look at that!
They aren't even the strong ones!
Goku leaves Krillin with the injured Yamcha!
And turns to face them!
Hahaha!
Why you gotta do us Yamcha...
Fans?!
Where the fuck did you get the plural from?
You mean, singular Yamcha fan, like...
Hahaha!
You agree to that, at least?
We kicked them!
Too many innocent people?
Well, that is...
I wonder if there's, like, a kill count in Dragon Ball.
Of, like, how many people actually died in the fucking Dragon Ball Z universe.
Stop it!
You bastards!
It was my understanding you wanted the streets free of onlookers.
Evidently, our solution does not please you.
Oh my god!
They did it!
That's it!
Follow me and we're gonna settle this!
Settle what?
Look, Yamcha's not even here anymore.
Goku leads the Androids to a deserted...
I mean, technically they already...
Technically it's deserted already, so, like, we didn't have to leave.
Hahaha!
Like...
I...
I don't...
Okay, like...
They already killed everybody there, so, like...
Hahaha!
It turns out Android 20 has been studying Goku and his friends ever since he defeated...
He informs them that, over time, he has analyzed and come to fully grasp the power they wield.
Android 20 is confident that victory will be his, but Goku only grins in response.
If all you know about me is from before I went to Namek...
Gotta keep the infrastructure...
Oh, that's...
That's true.
Rebuilding is hard.
Oh my god, he's going Super Saiyan!
I heard you can be a Super Saiyan god now.
If I'm the one these guys want...
Then that's what they're gonna get!
A most intriguing discrepancy, this dormant power.
It departs rather considerably from the data previously compiled.
But it is not remotely discouraging.
To be fair, like, he started gathering data when he was a fucking child.
He could still grow.
Android number 19 shall now operate as your executioner.
Is that right?
Fine.
Then get over here and fight me!
You're Super Saiyan god Super Saiyan?
The fuck does that mean?
Don't worry.
I know the one strat.
I will do this until it stops working.
The strat of all time.
You can't even get up here.
You can't...
Bro, you can't even fly up here.
Oh, let me get a little bit higher.
Let me get...
Never put it.
Okay.
As I was saying, you can't even...
You can't even get up here.
Look at this.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I'm sorry!
I'm not!
I didn't...
I didn't mean that.
I'm so sorry.
I am not.
So...
Holy shit.
Gus, he got up!
How?
He got up!
What is he doing?
What is he...
Okay.
I'm just like...
What is he doing?
He's just flying around.
All right.
There we go.
Now, what you gonna do?
Nothing.
That's right.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Now, what is he gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, god.
He's looking at me.
Guys.
I don't know what to do when he does that.
I...
I don't know when he does that.
What?
What did he do?
Like, what?
What?
What did you do?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
I gotta be angry.
Now, I'm mad.
That's it.
That's fine.
Angry Kamehameha!
That's right!
I'm angry now!
That's fucking right!
You don't like it when I make...
There we go.
Guys, you shouldn't have taught me the Kamehameha strat.
I...
I don't know why you taught me the...
Why did you teach me the cheese?
What?
Why?
Why did you teach me the cheese?
Guys...
Guys, you shouldn't have taught me the cheese, guys.
Like, you know that's all I'm gonna do now.
That's...
That's not like...
It's for your own good.
Oh, my God!
Guys, I unlocked Yamcha!
Goku loses consciousness after his battle with the androids when he's been given the medicine from Trunks.
He comes to a few days later.
During that time, androids 16, 17, 18 awaken, and to make matters worse, a creature named Cell has arrived.
Seeing the ultimate power is for child number two now.
It is through absorbing androids 17, 18 that Cell plans to attain his perfect form.
Now aware of his new foes, Goku enters the Hyperbolic Time Chamber so he can complete a year of training in just a single day.
I want any chance of winning battles to come, and I need to train hard enough to find a level beyond Super Saiyan.
Oh, God.
It's Super Saiyan time.
Beyond Super Saiyan time.
Goku explains his...
Why did the music just stop?
What the fuck?
It literally just stopped.
Out of nowhere.
It's starting.
Piccolo's getting ready to fight.
Piccolo's getting ready to fight?
Yeah, but who?
No.
Who is it?
Whoever it is, I can't sense their energy.
So it's gotta be one of the other androids.
Stop, Gohan.
We can't help it.
We're nowhere near their level right now.
Gohan, you're literally ten.
No, not even ten.
You're literally eight.
That energy.
It's gotta be Cell.
Not Cell!
All right, guys.
I need to use the bathroom real quick.
Oh, shit.
Okay, guys.
I'll be right back.
Guys, okay.
I can do...
I need to pick up one more game, because I need to pick up Dad.
I need to pick up Dad.
So I'll do...
Which one is the alternate...
Wait for...
Guys, I forgot.
Which one is the what-if scenario?
Go for help or wait for Vegeta and Trunks?
Which one is it?
Go help?
Go and help is the what-if?
Go and help is what-if.
Okay.
Don't worry.
If I use my instant transmission, I might be able to get out of here.
I might be able to get Piccolo out of there!
Don't worry.
Piccolo got you!
Thanks, Dad!
Please save him!
Don't worry, Gohan.
I'll save your real dad.
Don't worry.
Wait.
I'm in the canon event?
Guys, what the fuck?
Guys!
And you called me the fake...
Oh!
Hahaha!
Just as they arrive, Piccolo is attacked and morally wounded by Cell.
Oh, it's not Cat.
Guys!
There's a lot of fake fans in my chat!
At least I'm...
At least I admit that I don't remember certain things.
What's his energy, Gohan?
Yeah, fucking barely.
Look at him.
He's like literally gonna die.
Alright.
Alright, Gohan.
Watch your down.
Gohan, don't let your dad not get beat up like your fake dad.
This is why I'm a real dad, Gohan.
You try to say Gohan...
Piccolo's your real dad when look at him.
He fucking almost died.
Cell looks really good in this game.
Alright.
Don't worry.
It's time.
Oh shit.
I think he knows.
He knows the strat.
The other AIs told him about my strat.
The other AIs told him!
No, there's no way.
No, they didn't.
They didn't tell him everything.
Don't worry.
The other AIs didn't tell him everything.
They did tell him everything!
This is it!
I can still abuse it!
That's fucking right!
I cannot allow number 17 to be absorbed.
This is it!
You're actually gonna fight two?
By my calculations, Cell and I are approximately equal in size.
That's what you're gonna do?
Get closer to me?
That's...
What the fuck?
I'm so far.
Like, what are you trying to do?
I'm so fucking far.
Yeah, that's right.
Get closer.
Get hit by that bitch.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm not sorry.
Because I know you never learn.
You don't learn!
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
What?
How is he not dead?
Okay, now he's actually dead.
Okay.
We did it.
Yeah!
And that's how Goku beats every villain.
Guys, all I'm saying is you shouldn't have taught me the cheese.
That's all I'm saying.
We couldn't have avoided this.
Goku and friends have successfully defeated Cell.
Since their common enemy has been done away with, the androids returned to the original objective.
They're about to kill Goku.
However, the androids have suffered damage from their battle with Cell.
Oh shit.
What?
Listen.
Your bodies are way too injured to be fighting right now.
I'm not going anywhere.
Goku beats Cell.
Cell Saga has ended.
So why don't you rest up and do this another time?
What the hell are you talking about?
These little scrapes are nothing.
We could still take you easy.
What the fuck was wrong with his lip sync?
Don't throw me any sympathy.
I have no sympathy.
What the fuck?
What's that supposed to mean?
Look at his lip syncing!
He's just very angry, Doki.
Well, not naming numbers, but one of us was hogging all the action and ended up with a couple...
He's angry!
He's so angry.
Stretch your legs.
Yeah, whatever.
Okay, look!
That's normal!
You have any problems with that, 16?
Negative.
Good.
Glad we're on the same page.
Oh, yeah.
What was the what if sentence?
That's it?
Would you let me take this worm mail?
Alright, I'll do this one too.
I'll do this fight.
I literally have like 12 minutes left, but I'll do this fight too.
Just be careful, Goku.
He's no longer angry.
Alright.
Watch this.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry.
You can't do that forever.
No way!
You being as strong as you are is actually why I want to fight you one on one!
Oh, shit!
How are you strong as...
Okay, don't worry.
Matches up with yours.
That's all.
I'm not done yet.
Don't start getting ahead of yourself.
It's fine.
She flew down.
She flew down, guys.
She...
18.
I'm in love with it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
What you gonna do?
Huh?
What you gonna do?!
Nothing!!
That's right!
That's really not...
What you're gonna do?!?
You have to reach me first!!
That's right!!!
Can't even get out of the water!
OOOOOOOH, OH MY GOD!
WHAT?!
I'm sorry!
You're so beautiful!
I'm so sorry!
I'm not sorry!
I'll never be sorry!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Pew!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Oh, shit!
I wanted it to be... pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Wait, wait, I can kill her with this.
Watch this.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Oh, god!
Pew, pew, pew!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Wait, wait.
Yeah!
The Vegeta technique!
Easy.
So easy.
Cool!
The cheese!
How could you kick her like that!?
You don't fear your power, Goku!
Goku taunts Android 18, all while remaining perfectly calm.
That allows them to gain advantage in their fight.
Android 18 soon realizes she is losing and decides to abandon her fight with Goku.
Ugh.
That's enough.
Now my clothes are dirty.
No, I ruined her- I dirtied up her face!
Wait, you're done?
No!
That was so quick!
Untouchable as I am, I don't get that much of a kick out of fighting.
Had enough time to lick your wounds?
You know androids don't run out of energy like that.
I swear.
You're the naggiest sibling in the world.
I like OceanDub's voice for Android 17 more.
I don't like this guy's voice.
This is the first time I heard Android 17's voice in the new dub.
And I think OceanDub's voice for him is a lot better.
Gotta say, Goku.
You're as impressive a martial artist as the doctor said.
That.
And you're not nearly as annoying as that hothead, Vegeta.
You kept your cool throughout that whole fight with 18 too.
Making an android with unlimited energy sweat- I'm just an OceanDub- THAT'S RIGHT!
I AM!
That's right!
I am!
And I'll never- I'll never- And I'll fight every other dub.
Stop.
That's right... it's all we had.
It was literally all that we had.
But it was perfect.
Oh my God!
He learned from 18.
How?!
You were supposed to let me cheese you!
You were- And- JK,, nevermind.
It's working.
As soon as I pick him up in the water you can't do anything.
As soon- As soon as- He's watching Doki, of course he knows.
He literally watched the entire fight, Doki.
Like, what's he supposed to do?
Not watch?
Yeah, because that's rude.
It was a private fight.
Oh no, he's in the air.
Don't worry, I got the skybox now.
This is mine.
Wait, what are you doing?
That's right, you know you're beneath me.
That's fucking right.
Get down!
You know damn well you're beneath me.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not.
Oh my god.
Okay, I am sorry.
Where am I?
Good.
Unless I go first.
You can't finish this if I'm here first.
God damn it.
Get over here.
I'll punch you with my hands now.
I know how much HP I have.
You thought you're better than me?
Alright, punch me.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
Now I can Kamehameha.
Only let my guard down for a second.
So easy.
Look at that.
I actually fought.
Look at that!
I used my hands!
Oh wait, he's happy.
Realizing he can't defeat Goku, Android 17 lowers his guard.
However, his expression seems somewhat pleased.
Android 17 who had searched for Goku as if it were a game.
Feels like he had enough fun with that fight.
I think I'm a little burnt out on all the fighting.
Takaya, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Those are Android 17's words to Android 16 and 18.
Android 16's gaze remained displeased as he stares at Goku.
Why?
What's the deal?
We going or what?
What did I do wrong, 16?
What?
I saved your life, bro.
16, what got into you all of a sudden?
You look pissed.
Yeah, what did I do?
My mission is to kill Goku and I intend to accomplish it.
Dude, chill.
Bro.
What is that?
What's that actually?
There's no way that was in the anime.
Bro.
Dude, chill.
Dude, wait.
What's that thing?
Dude.
Oh, this is the what if.
There's no way.
I was going to say there's no way.
Bro, dude, chill.
Dude.
That's so...
That's so good, though.
I'm sorry.
That's actually so funny, bro.
Bro, chill, bro.
I know.
It's pretty much on brand, but it's such a funny line.
Wait, do I get this off first?
I think I do.
Yeah, that's right.
Enough what, huh?
Oh!
It's okay.
I can charge this up.
Oh, it's okay.
You can...
It's fine.
You can still hit me.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
This is the only thing I know how to...
Don't let him grab me.
Get away.
Chat told me I can't let you grab me.
Look, fighting games is all about fighting.
The spam.
I'm just doing what I'm supposed to be doing guys.
Where is he?
Oh, where did he go?
Did I get it?
Is he.
Where is he?
Bro.
Oh, wait.
He's over there.
He is which gets him....
I'm just like, is he okay?
Is he okay?
Are you gonna come over?
Is he... hello?
Hello?
Oh shit!
That's not how he gave up!
Oh my god, he actually...
Guys, I did not expect that.
I did not expect that.
Oh no!
No!
No, don't grab me!
Don't grab me, I'm so scared!
Don't grab me, please!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Oh!
You can?
Oh god, okay.
It's okay.
You can't read this though!
Even though I did it 20 times!
You still can't read this!
You're so stupid!
If you can read my movement, why still haven't you predicted this?
Give me your energy, everybody!
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
I'm so excited now!
That's right!
Oh shit!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
But can you do... can you dodge this?
Oh!
It all comes down to this.
Get in the water.
Yay!
I get it!
If you're not, if you're not, if you're not, if you're not, if you're not, if you're not, you're gonna die a thousand times.
Don't you dare, 16.
I'm not letting you blow yourself up.
That's right.
Now you die in the water.
Don't tell me.
You have a self-destruct device I'm disassociating from this Kamehameha voice.
I'm disassociating from this Kamehameha voice.
Why would I make it harder for myself?
I told you both before.
My mission is to kill Goku.
At any cost.
Then why haven't you already?
Yeah.
You could wipe this entire island off the map with that explosion.
Exactly.
He's just tsundere.
That's enough!
You can't beat me in the state you're in now.
Exactly.
And besides, you don't really seem like a bad guy.
Even if you're technically a robot, I can feel your intent to kill.
But if it really is your mission, why didn't you go for it trying to find a cell?
Instead, you chose to defend your fellow androids.
Which means...
It's simple.
For the birds.
There is much wildlife living all around this island.
I did not want to obstruct nature with the fallout of our battles.
So, Oh my god.
But hear me, Goku.
Nerd!
One day, when you're in your bathroom, you will never expect me.
I took care not to harm any innocent life, animal nor human.
I believe you are both good people.
Whatever.
When you close your eyes, I'm gonna be there outside the window, Goku.
I have enjoyed traveling together.
Well, who says we can't still keep doing it?
Then you know what?
Let's have our first stop by the mall.
By the mall?
Where do you have the money?
By the fucking mall?
It looks like the battle is over.
Yup.
Goku!
Let's all go to the mall today.
Where's Cell?
And the androids?
And 18?
You didn't beat them all already, did you?
Well, I think they'll be back.
Gohan, this is why I'm your real dad.
Not this pussy ass Piccolo shit.
What?
I nearly beat up four people.
Piccolo got beat up by one.
In the wake of Cell's defeat, the three androids depart.
Peace is once again restored.
Oh yeah, Krillin, sorry.
You're not gonna have a girlfriend or a wife now.
I'm sorry.
In this timeline, Krillin never finds a wife.
Someday, these powerful artificial humans may show their faces again.
No, it's life!
We did it!
The perfect ending!
Now Gohan respects me as a real dad.
And Krillin never gets laid.
Whatever the outcome, Goku is sure to be stronger than ever.
Krillin loses in this timeline.
This is the worst time.
It's the best time!
The timeline for Goku!
It's...
Goku gets the best ending!
Alright, guys.
GG everybody.
I actually have to stop because I need to pick up my dog.
But it was fun.
It was fun.
I had a good time playing.
I think I might try the Kakarot.
I think like, honestly, I think I would prefer playing the Kakarot game.
I think because this one is like...
I want to enjoy the story more.
Like, relive the story.
But it has been fun.
It has been fun.
Stop spamming and learn!
But it works though!
But it works!
It works!
Yeah, this was more of a fighting game based.
But then I just kept commenting on it.
You guys should have taught me the cheese.
You guys...
If I didn't know the cheese I would have never done this.
The AI could have learned but it didn't.
It's not my fault.
The AI didn't catch up in time.
But I had a great time.
So I was really unhinged earlier, guys.
Sick Doki Bird is...
Sick Doki Bird gets really unhinged.
And a little unfiltered there.
I'm sorry.
I hope...
I hope you guys...
No, please!
No, please, guys!
Anyway, guys.
I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Tomorrow we have two streams.
We have a Deadlock tournament stream.
Wait, I think... is Goombie messaging me about the team?
Okay.
Wait.
Who...
Oh, shit!
Who are the...
Wait, what the fuck?
Who are the teammates so I can give this to Organizer?
I don't know if Goombie is still online.
Apparently, we have a full party with a few sweats.
Wait, what?
Guys, I don't wanna...
Guys, we are not supposed to make it to day two, guys.
We are not supposed...
This stream is Frieza Force approved.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This stream is sponsored by the Ginyu Force.
Okay, it is Seijam, Raditz, and Void.
Void, Rambling, and me.
Who... Okay, I don't know like half of these people.
Who?
Who are they?
Okay, Void.
Someone's just named Void?
Who's Void?
Is this GSM Void?
Who's this guy?
Alright.
He is a...
Are they all fighting gameplays?
World's greatest gamer.
Okay.
Oh, he plays...
He plays Deadlock.
Oh, shit.
There are Deadlock players.
Okay, who's Rambling?
You got...
No, Raditz.
Oh my god, you got Raditz?
Who's...
Who's Raditz?
Who's that guy?
Yeah.
Am I supposed to...
What the fuck is Raditz doing?
She got...
Oh my god.
I got...
I got Raditz.
Enjoy.
Alright.
This guy is...
I don't... Who's Raditz?
Raditz.
Not Raditz.
I know who... Wait, does he play Deadlock?
Yeah, he does.
Okay, I see him stream Deadlock.
Okay, and then we have Rambling.
Damn, that's insane.
We're not supposed to go to Day 2, guys.
That's... We're not supposed to go to Day 2.
Okay.
And then we have Rambling.
Okay, that's our team.
And then we have Gumiya and Seijan.
Alright!
If we make it to Day 2...
I...
Well...
It's just Karma at that point.
It's just Karma.
If we...
If we make it to Day 2...
It's just... It's just Karma.
It's like...
It's just Karma.
Anyway...
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm gonna rest and relax now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Oh, yeah!
Tomorrow, the collab with Sykkuno, Elem, and Chilled is gonna be a rematch of Mario Party.
Elem's not gonna be hosting the server this time.
It's a...
It's a rematch.
Alright, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Monkey.